foreign
[Music]
EK
[Music]
okay castles
Caucasian Andy
[Music]
[Music]
um
let's go here
let's go here
let's go D4
this is his bruta
Hotel
brother from another mother
foreign
[Music]
foreign
why do people like coffee well speak for
yourself I did not used to like the
taste of coffee but it's I would not I
would never drink a decaf I would never
have it over like tea the fact that it's
caffeinated honestly makes it taste
better like it's a placebo effect
also some coffees are just genuinely
really good tasting
[Music]
to me decaf is like sacrilege
I'm 98. I mean that H5
it doesn't work
why am I thinking to I'm thinking too
long
mistake
oh he's playing with Rey by Liam
you mother
he's cheating on me he's having an
affair
is committing adultery
I will not take kindly to that I'm
filing for divorce
Rebecca is filing Rebecca does not
accept stuff like this
how did he get out of this
how did he get out of this this was
completely winning and now I feel like
I'm losing control to the point where I
might not even be better
okay what was Rook A7 was also done
because it doesn't actually carry a
threat
of course
of course
yeah man
definitely was winning
yeah I just can't believe Magnus is
cheating on me
so upsetting
now this this stuff again
Mrs Harris has already hired lawyers
I've forgiven him once
I won't do it again
Mrs Harris is about to become Ms Harris
I'm definitely taking the kids
full custody
there's Doubtfire
I'm gonna pull a Missed Out Fire
phenomenal movie by the way
probably my favorite childhood movie
help is on the way dear yeah exactly
exactly I remember that phrase help is
on the way
oh
continue
I have FG though
Sally Field is great yeah
no the best the most tear-jerker divorce
movie is Kramer versus Kramer if you
want to cry
it's from 1979 with Dustin Hoffman and
Meryl Streep I think
what do you say when Meryl has a sore
throat
she has a strep throat okay
um what is it she
Kavita to Peter perturbed grubhaj
an
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I don't know what to do
thank you man
okay we're gonna repeat this about the
next setup
hmm
yeah this idea of going Rook B8 and B6
is very very powerful
hmm
I'm kind of out of my league here
I never know if Knight D5 is correct
yeah this is outside my pay grade
midsomar I didn't like
I watched midsomar It's been somar is is
I think too meta for me
yeah I have a very simple taste I like
movies that I can understand
hereditary was terrible I I honestly
hated it I didn't get it at all
I I am a skeptic in the sense that I
feel like
I'm not just gonna agree that a movie is
brilliant just because I don't
understand it I think there's like a
cultural Trend anything that we can't
understand mostly because it's genius it
cannot be because it's poorly made
it must be because you don't understand
the sophistication and the the Nuance of
it
foreign
Rook C8 but what
girl
okay I see what he wants he wants to
trap me
tarkovsky has some good movies yeah
I've only seen I've only seen
um like I think two tarkovsky movies
thank you
synecdoche oh that I used to know what
that word means
oh he's gonna go Bishop H6
Solaris I've seen yeah
Solaris I didn't like
Solaris I did not like
stalker is good yeah
she's gonna figure something out here he
always does
yeah I can I can set I can
see the wheels turning in his head
how do I trick this mofo hereditski
he's not gonna do it
how do you like that technique
whoa sorry that's Prague against Jose ah
ah
what the heck okay this is annoying
yeah he loves this G4 he likes to play
G4
[Music]
there it is
okay what if I tried D5 I'm gonna try to
punish him
take take the Ed Knight F3 mate
I have no idea who Sinister Magnus is
literally none
and I won't speculate I haven't seen a
single one of his games
how do you like them apples my boy's
Wicked smot
yeah I've never seen Sons of Anarchy
okay my position officially sucks now
although if I can get F5 and maybe okay
forget scratch that
scratch that
I wonder how Magnus is doing
I guess Magnus just wanted some variety
like he played a thousand games against
me yesterday
yeah I mean the thing is
when we see was Implement Magnus I mean
we've seen him play Magnus everything
with Diaz of course he gets crushed Mac
Magnum speaking class classical game you
know ding new College you know between
100 but you know
um
okay let's go
gunning for you thanks oh shoot he's got
Queen H6
holy juice
Mr gambini are you mocking me
what are you wearing
I'm wearing a closer on her
it's my cousin Vinnie I mean everybody
should know that if you don't know that
reference leave the stream watch the
movie and then come back
No Country for Old Men actually might be
the top five movies yeah
I'm gonna lose the game if I play C6
when I'm gonna play it anyway
I have to control D5 Square
so you're gonna Master this fruit of
this transmission mucha gracias
okay once here
I have no time
no I think somebody on Reddit did an
analysis my score with Magnus is
generally much better than my score
against NACA
actually
quite a bit better
um I I can sense that this game is
getting out of control
I think if he takes I'll take back
maybe I should have gone Rook F6 I
definitely should have gone Rook F6
yeah Hikaru is faster all things hold
equal so I can do less of the dirty
Flags
foreign
yeah I had no chance
oh my gosh 25.
I was too low on time this game I need
to be faster in the opening
I was definitely better but I just
didn't have any time
should have maybe gone for the three to
three-fold repetition I had a chance
to be a lot faster in the opening
oh again it's doing this
again it's doing this thing
why was why did they need to do this
stupid update and it was perfectly fine
thank you ratchet Allen
I'm frozen no I'm not frozen
okay I'm trying to play faster and more
accurately
thank you vanish for the 10 bucks thank
you appreciate it
okay this is also hanging
maybe I shouldn't have done that I
should have just gone
should not have done that but okay upon
is a pawn
I do it to do
I'm gonna go Queen F3 I'm gonna go with
my gut
wow what a move
what a move
I don't trust it
stress of the bits
soon enough
okay Knight D6 and now I think I'm in
pretty decent shape here
I guess
all right almost flooded that
hmm
well he's already on the mend here
am I even better maybe not
is black magic
is taking to go here
[Music]
you know the confidence with which he
defends is his next level
this is next level
six
okay he allows F4 interesting
I don't know
why he allowed that move exactly
now I think maybe I have a little
something again
okay I can go bishopy too
I think I probably should because
there's Rook F2
when did I have Bishop takes too far
no I didn't have Bishop before
now I'm gonna play Bishop D4
ah it just goes there
with me
trying to trick him here
amazing
here maybe
he defends like Magnus Carlson on this
thing
okay I gotta play faster to avoid
getting flagged
and I probably will still lose
[Music]
foreign
that is unbelievable that is just
unbelievable
that's what that's what happens when you
over press in these situations against
Rebecca
man my heart is like beating out of my
chest
I thought I was gonna lose because at
some point I had like five seconds to
ten and it was already like
borderline loss position
but then I realized I have the drawing
mechanism in place and there's not much
you could do about it
okay now we gotta follow up with the win
of the black pieces
okay
I mean I am aware of that
he's relentlessly going after me here
Sam
yeah
actually makes it look easy let's go
here
oh
this move hmm
okay let's try this move
obviously incredibly risky but I don't
see an alternative
I'm not really a runner but I hope to
become come one
C4
no words
okay we're gonna get a pawn down
position so I'm gonna try to hold
he's playing a brilliant game
not sure what I should do here
oh and that was it was very dumb to
prove okay whatever
oh he's got C5 but he doesn't see it
[Music]
so accurate
wait you just blundered one sec oh no
you didn't need any skg one
Rook A1 is not a move he might also be
missing that
she isn't
okay
let's go here I gotta move
yeah I almost messed it up
foreign
[Music]
he's just he's just too fast
somehow it's removing everything even
though I was the one checking him
but with him it doesn't matter he'll
just find ways to pre-move
yeah I had that game completely in my
pocket if I just played a little faster
[Music]
I feel like I've gotten a little bit
slower with this new update for some
reason
just not moving quite as crisply
[Music]
foreign
shouldn't probably Queen D4 was totally
unnecessary
although it shouldn't hurt
nice God's just simply this move
um
faster
foreign
[Music]
game
but okay I mean these time scrambles are
going to be 50 50.
[Music]
maybe five would kill me kill me here
let's go here
yeah I think this is supposed to be bad
for black I'm not sure exactly how it
goes
oh Alexander is better bite but not by a
lot
I would say mikola is much harder to
play for me personally
okay he's
he's already crushing me out of the
opening like it's not even close
I need to look this up
six is coming
six is coming and I'm not sure
if I have even a single move
even Bishop F4 probably is good for
white but E6 just looks crushing
no I need to I need to play something
else with black this is overstated to
welcome this line
he's adapted to it
okay plays Bishop F4 I thought maybe
here
Queen A5 gives an inkling of Hope
[Music]
I'm sure what white has a win but
maybe I can try to survive this
I think Alexander and men are very
similar in strength
they're comparable completely different
players though totally different styles
frankly I hate playing both Nikola and
Alexander because they're so tricky
and they get out of like the Alexander
McCullough both get out of the Lost
positions regularly
[Music]
these amazing but he's I mean why butt
can he be amazing and be a young dad
are these mutually exclusive
yeah Castle's Queen side very accurate
move
very accurate
I don't hate playing everyone
but I
I enjoy playing period but I was just
certain people are a lot more
frustrating to play than others
oh oh I see what you're saying no that's
I wouldn't know but I think that's true
as far as I know I'm not a dad
hey Caraway is definitely frustrated I
mean the car is really fun to play but
he's also frustrating
obviously he's frustrating to play
Hikaru is just a bottomless pit of
despair
like
yeah I have absolutely no moves here
aha wait maybe this
but he must think the same thing playing
me like I know what people don't like
playing me either
are you kidding me
works
yeah I have to go like this
try to go for some comp with the two
pieces but
I don't think this is enough
um
I can't defend everything here at the
same time
okay
I had A5
actually a thread now
wait but he has no defense I think
suddenly he's busted
I think he's totally bust out here
because King D1 I have Bishop G4
wow
yeah goodbye
take everything
this I think I'll be able to have three
pieces in a rook suddenly
okay obviously I'm not gonna stalemate
you mikola
I'm not gonna stalemate you mikola
goodbye
whoa that was a nice one that was spicy
right there
H5 we live
A6 we in the mix
that was some H5 we live right there
a Magnus is killing Rey I think
yeah that was that was really nice I
found the right way to keep pieces for
the queen I I knew when I got the two
pieces I didn't want to jinx it but I
could sense that it was a lot of
compensation
yeah these two pieces for the queen is
so underrated
the way the way they coordinate
well I think the reason some people
don't like playing me is is the same
reason I don't like playing other people
it was like very tricky
Magnus is winning 5-1 yeah I mean that's
pretty normal for Magnus
okay I'm up a pawn for very questionable
comp but
let's go Queen B3
to be fast
maybe G4 was interesting but I don't
particularly like it
he wants G5 I can go Bishop G4 but then
he takes no
hmm
excuse me
yeah I should have gone Queen A3
actually it would have been much much
better
much much better
this aware unfortunately
okay let's go here this feels right take
Stakes Rook C4 I'll go Queen
B3
analytical I don't understand what that
means
and he goes exactly for the line that I
was very worried about
yeah this has been a complete 180.
I'm just gonna bring all my pieces close
to the king
okay it should not be worse here
should not be worse here
okay goes back to F6 which is good let's
go Knight G3 build up the
beef on the king beef up the security on
the king's side he's probably gonna go
H5
and then yeah let's go H4 I don't and
maybe H4 is bad it Saddles the Knight
but I didn't want to allow him to go
h4h3
okay take it
so I have six let's go B6
294 but it's okay
or maybe it's not okay
no it's definitely not okay that I
missed that
if they forgot about that mouth
all right he's got Bishop D4 too
[Music]
yeah yeah let's go back all back back we
go
foreign
oh
okay
he took too long there I think
now what do we want to play with black I
I really we're back to square zero
okay let's go G6 but let's let's play D5
let's play this side line
which of course I'm sure he knows all
right goes for the end game okay
I don't mind an end game against him
actually
maybe I should go Bishop C7 but I I'm
gonna stick with my gut here
castles Queen said okay he wants Bishop
C3 I guess
okay let's go out
I don't think anybody has a plus score
against Carlson and Blitz know
me
[Music]
I blundered this move oh yeah
yeah
fortunately this does not lose a piece
but it
definitely changes the landscape of the
position in his favor still I should be
able to hold
okay I'm not worried about E60 6f King
takes C6
no I I still think I'm fine actually
what helps me here is the fact that his
pawns on the Queen Center all right but
he's starting to harass me
uh that's such an annoying move
it's such an annoying move I need to
find a tactical solution here I have an
idea
I think I can go here
hmm
amazing okay what's happening here I
guess I have to go E6
okay
now I can finally defend the pawn
now we can get rid of the Knight if I
wanted to
hmm
I do want to
foreign
maybe this is a mistake I'm not sure
I thought I had a fortress but maybe not
actually
emphasis on maybe not
I'm just gonna get zugged here
just lost
let's go here
huh
actually okay I have one chance which is
to play oh
man if I could get my knight to D7 it
would be made
I'm threatening made in one
I'm also fighting men in one two
different ways uh wait up wait I'll put
up he's gotta move his Knight
and then maybe Knight A4 can be six
wait wait wait wait this is not this is
not so clear all of a sudden
this is not so clear all of a sudden
right he just allowed King beefing oh
so tricky
oh no
you just tricked me I have to go back
H5 of course but it's fine
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's go
oh
that took all the magic in the world
that was definitely lost I think
to begin with
[Music]
okay with this
[Music]
I see three Queen B3 I think is the
point because he's six interesting
wait I don't trust this
foreign
okay I gotta make a decision here
let's go like this now I thought maybe
rookie six
yeah I calculated this
95
wait am I losing or something okay
whatever
now Blaine is taking
we have to competition
but okay maybe I can hold that position
yeah these long calculation he usually
gets the better of me
[Music]
means damn
[Music]
okay takes I think I can get away with
taking I'm just gonna do it I it doesn't
I mean I'm hanging by a threat if he
takes I take back with Chuck
it's eight one damn girl he's 32-53
and he's he's bit enough
a lot there
okay you know do I just lose no I don't
lose that Rook be one let's think if I
have anything else
I don't think I do
oh wait I have Queen A1 Maybe
Queen A1 oh I gotta move crap in no time
when I want to rock F7 though
it takes oh wait did I
shoot I Gotta Move
I gotta move
to draw probably that's all I have
maybe I can play H3 but it's probably
too dangerous
wait isn't there mate here
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait yeah goodbye okay
great that's why it's too great yeah I
might just go back to E4 and I win
foreign
I don't get this move
like I once maybe 94.
okay but then Bishop G7
because if C4 I have A6
so I keep the two Bishops
foreign
[Music]
position is equal
position is equal
I'm definitely not better here I mean
it's
maybe a smidge
smidge nasal but not much
[Music]
I'm gonna go rookie six maybe double
Rooks
foreign
[Music]
Knight C4 D5 is nasty potentially
[Music]
let's go H6 okay let's create some lifts
oh shoot he's got this move Berlin
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna go for a risk
I'm gonna go for it just because I'm
leading I'm gonna make a very
opportunistic move I normally wouldn't
make
[Music]
I feel like he's his confidence is
shattered right now so
maybe not
yeah I'm gonna go for a pawn SEC hoping
that I get enough activity hopium
and G5 Maybe I was hoping he would
blunder rookie three addicted
okay and now this is all I saw
[Music]
now of course this is totally and
utterly unsound utterly unsound
[Music]
and I'm busted
it's gonna go D5
I'm sort of busted here
okay it doesn't go D5
I thought it would go up D5 now I want
to go C5 actually
not anymore
no time either
oh I had Knight H3 maybe ah
ah nice looking H2 I guess
on the queen of whatever
too late
too late
whoa
oh crap
yeah I'm losing
today
foreign
foreign
foreign
my Pace a little bit here
no I think he's losing because I'm
playing better chest than him
but that's just a hypothesis I'm not
really sure why one would lose games
people on Twitch are in love with using
tilt as an explanation for absolutely
everything like loose it must be tilt
this must be tilt that must be the only
reason
because sometimes there's other factors
at play
well I saw it there's a trick there it
would have won immediately if he fell
for it
[Music]
yeah choking is like anytime you lose a
game it's like joke
okay let's fix the weakness
okay King E7 I mean this is completely
winning but it's like not that simple
like am I going to
like yeah
Queen she's like totally winning
okay wait B6 and Knight B5 is
interesting
yeah let's do it this feels right
B7 Maybe
[ __ ] I'm
I'm definitely messing this up a little
bit but it's okay it's okay
it's all right
okay I broke F7
or I can maybe I can just play it simple
takes here oh he's got oh my gosh
unfortunately I have this move without
which I'd be lost
okay I need to move a little faster I'm
still in good shape
not all has been lost
thank you cagex for the 20 months
ity
I know I can't take
so freaking resilient
[Music]
hmm
foreign
[Music]
after this game
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
bladder has been successfully emptied
all right
okay he wants another end game that's
fine with me
toity
hoity toity
that was like way TMI I like
yeah like like why did you have to like
say that
like am I going to
my equals totally exactly
oh my God I just like missed this check
advice okay wait you can give me seven
I'm worse here though let's get serious
because I am worse
program out watch it
[Music]
I am I
you want to send me vulgar Russian
messages I am the mod so careful
what's amazing is how bad this position
is for Black
[Music]
Asana is just a terrible position
[Music]
yeah this b-break allowed him time to
reset reset
I'm not gonna win this position I think
if I win this position
you just know it's my freaking day
I think the strategy has to be to trade
if I can trade all of the Rooks then
I'll have chances
okay I also have this idea Knight GA
Bishop H6 essentially
okay he allows it interesting
hmm
no this has to be fine for me now
very strange that he
I see he's still better but I think I
should be able to hold it now
let me think about how I want to arrange
my pieces
yeah he asked if Russian ladies Court me
if I get wooed
Russian is very bad in Google Google
Translates very very bad at Russian
in my experience
like it's rare to get anything that
makes any degree of sense
I mean it's an immature question
yeah my performance of Magnus is getting
Justified right now
given what he's doing to Rey
oh he's got freaking Bishop Point Within
now this is over yeah Bishop F1 I missed
that
it's bad very bad news
[Music]
should I win this
he's gonna play like age four and made
himself
one thing is he's his confidence is down
so I need to sow the seeds of doubt in
his mind
I should have put a bishop on E5
should have obviously put a bush 25 but
okay I have this okay
oh no
yeah I had such a good chance if I'd put
a bishop on E5 simply
[Music]
let's go here
here letters upon
I have still of chance though
yeah no I'm not I'm not even risking it
draw great results given that end game
we're good
okay
fine
okay let's strike in the center that's
how we want to meet this line Jeffrey to
nimso Indian thank you
foreign
so I started streaming the Magnus match
but then I decided against I decided
that I wanted to focus on the on the
match
I guess he has Rook C8 wow no he doesn't
plan wait what
girl what
girl
kind of that I feel like I'm very close
to losing control of this game
foreign
take all the spawns that's what I'm
gonna do
it's just what I'm gonna do
t
can I get away with just a signature
[Music]
probably a bad idea but I'm gonna play
it anyway
probably a really bad idea to play
Knight A5
Rook A6 I have Knight C7
28
it's his idea yeah okay
Bishop A4 I just moved my queen I think
I'm fine
Rook a5ba
now where do we want to move it
probably just D2 or am I missing
something
gosh it feels like it feels like I'm
missing something here but I don't see
it
now I'm threatening Knight C7 okay yeah
I knew he would do that
what does he want
the [ __ ]
I don't I just don't get it
the hell does he want what if I just go
freaking Queen somewhere
E4 B4 I don't know
I don't know where to go
okay whatever
what do you want from me mikola stop
sacrificing your pieces you're making me
uncomfortable
violating my safe space
okay am I crazy or did he just offer a
queen trade when he's done in exchange
in 50 bonds oh at 49 Pawns
it's obviously not that simple to win
this
foreign
so he's gonna fight
to the last drop of blood and it's
what's helping
him is the fact that I keep blundering
my goddamn Pawns
um
[ __ ]
I'm good I did not actually at it it's
still winning
okay let's go here
it's winning it's winning
oh it gives me a check I'm lost after
frick I'm getting made to death knight
E3 and then I can resign
oh F5 yeah that that wins for black
actually yeah
it's gonna be a very hard conversion
act acting career I mean I mean acting
Deanna is just
um okay
um let's go
okay let's keep going
I mean you could play could play board
then completely
improp problem let me call board [ __ ]
just that
um
all right this is a disaster
this is a complete catastrophe
this is catastroph
IC
okay
dude
nice
I have to take like this through
clenched teeth
okay we need a freaking Swindle of the
century here
I'm very impressed with his ability to
not tell actually he's tilted
surprisingly little given the score of
the match
yeah the last two games have gone very
very difficult
okay we had to prevent C4 at all costs
maybe I should have gone Rook Cafe
this is like the kind of position that
he's it really excels at it's like open
but it's also very flimsy for me
yeah here we go this bull crap again
this is [ __ ]
we don't take Conley to that in the
south
we don't take kind later these kinds of
moves
all right now we're gonna take Hayer
energy protein shake we're gonna
simplify
[Music]
okay I have no time also
The Rook C1
and we're just gonna go like D5 or
something Queen C5 while very like
what's kind of what what's gotten into
him
what's gotten into him
what are all these frequency magnets now
you see my man Matt Magnus
Frontier Magnus
all right let's go if he goes Knight E3
I'll go Knight F4
I'm more than happy with the draw
of course he is not
okay let's go night before I mean if I
don't
get active I'm gonna lose without a
fight
oh shoot wait but now I can go back
maybe
this is
[Music]
now I have this move
[Music]
foreign
s
how does he do it
foreign
foreign
thank you Lily
foreign
[Music]
foreign
Bishop A3
right I think I'm gonna go after this
game
I still have to do my new interest
article and
I don't want to go too late and I have a
tournament coming up so
want to get some sleep
I'll do a speedrun game I'll do one and
then I'll get going after this game
hopefully I can win it and stick The
Landing here
boy choking
let's bring the Rook into the game
it's Knight F6 okay
it's a good move
I but I'm I'm messing this up pretty
hardcore actually
I'm really messing this up
foreign
I'm trying to win this still
which is risky because now I'm like
borderline
Danger
okay let's just
go there
[Music]
thank you
foreign
that's how we end it
that's how we end it
[Music]